when the economy screeched to a halt and
mid-march businesses shut down almost
overnight and quickly millions of
workers became unemployed within weeks
the government moved to provide
trillions of dollars of stimulus relief
to workers and businesses throughout the
economy $1200 checks to anyone who makes
less than $75,000 this is another $600 a
week for four months Congress approving
another four hundred and eighty four
billion dollars for loans so where does
all this money come from
is it taxpayer funds is the government
printing a bunch of new cash as you
might expect there's a lot more to know
Congress can authorize taxes to pay for
new spending but that's not where the
stimulus money is coming from that money
is being raised through borrowing the
government expects to borrow a record
four point five trillion dollars for the
fiscal year that ends in September
that's more than three times the one
point to eight trillion dollars it
borrowed the year prior that borrowed
money is being used to subsidize small
business payrolls send checks to
households and offer taxpayers a
temporary holiday on making tax payments
the Treasury Department is in charge of
the borrowing the agency borrows by
selling Treasury bills or bonds to the
three main groups of savers the public
sector like other parts of the
government the private sector which
includes companies or individuals like
you and me and foreign entities these
bills are like IOUs
someone agrees to buy them and the
government agrees to pay them back with
a little bit of interest in the meantime
the government can use that borrowed
money for stimulus to support private
individuals and companies or state and
local governments this year the federal
government will get most of its
borrowing from the private sector and
the reason for that is because private
borrowers who would normally be
competing with the federal government
for private savings basically
disappeared that stimulus money can make
the economy larger than it otherwise
would have been it encourages employers
to keep people employed and it
encourages individuals to spend here's a
hypothetical example let's say Congress
authorizes 1 billion dollars in stimulus
spending the Treasury would borrow 1
billion by selling Treasury bills it
would then use that borrowed money on
the stimulus programs with the hopes of
keeping the economy churning but it
doesn't end there
if the economy keeps moving households
and businesses can keep earning income
and some of that income can be saved and
in the future they can use those savings
to invest in more Treasury bills
supplying the government with more money
to spend the amount of saving in the
economy is not a fixed amount federal
stimulus can actually result in more
people working more firms having profits
higher incomes and would have been the
case if there hadn't been any federal
stimulus at all this is known as
Keynesian stimulus names where the
British economist John Maynard Keynes
who first came up with the concept back
in the 1930s the government is not like
a family that has a fixed amount and
can't borrow more than it can pay back
and because it'll go bankrupt government
can in effect borrow enough to actually
make the economy bigger now on top of
the three main sources of borrowing
there's another source to the Federal
Reserve the central bank is like the
other sources but with a key difference
the Fed can raise funds to buy
Treasuries by simply printing money so
when we say the Fed is printing money we
don't literally mean it's firing up the
printing presses and creating paper
money and what we mean is that basically
clicks a button and credit the
Treasury's account with this money it's
electronic money it's not paper money in
effect the Treasury sells a bond and in
return gets brand-new money
right now the Fed is ramping up its
lending assets on the central bank's
balance sheet topped six point seven
trillion dollars during the first week
of May 2020 that gives the Treasury more
money to spend on stimulating the
economy and other programs critics of
the stimulus say the government
competing with other borrowers for
savings will push up interest rates
making it harder for private companies
and individuals to borrow and invest
they also say that if the Fed prints
money to finance the borrowing that will
lead to inflation and economic turmoil
like what seen in Venezuela and the
trillion dollar notes seen in Zimbabwe
it's only a problem if they print and
they print and they print and those
dollars get spent and spent and spend
again until all that spending far
exceeds the supply of goods and services
in our economy that's when you get high
inflation how will we know that's
happening well we probably see long-term
interest rates start to rise as
investors get ready for the approach of
inflation then we start to see actual
inflation rise so we're not seeing that
now